you talk about
love
dad why why
because it works we tune into succession
each week to get a look at the Roy
family in part because it gives us a
chance to say well our family's not
quite that messed up or hey I know that
that's my family hey GQ it's Dr Eric
Bender again I'm back to talk about
succession and some of the characters in
the show
[Music]
Logan Roy
when you talk about succession you have
to start with Logan Roy he would have it
no other way in the first episode of the
Season he's showing some signs of
illness and suddenly there's this fight
among his kids to see who is going to
take over the corporation if you
actually look at the theme song though
that's where we see the very first
images of him we see these children that
are dressed up they're playing tennis
they're doing all kinds of things but if
you notice they're alone the father's in
the distance he's walking through a
field or even at the table he's at the
head at a distance that's very common
and that's what is the unifying theme
Here for all the kids that their father
is not present he's not with them it's a
pleasure to have you here tonight to
honor
my Dad's life and work
when his son introduces Logan Kendall
says here we are to celebrate my dad and
the camera pans to Logan he's alone he's
at a table all by himself Logan's
complex in that he is a narcissist so
what narcissism is if you go by a
psychological psychiatric definition
include someone who feels that they're
special They pursue power Beauty wealth
kids don't really fit into that except
in how could they help him do that
and they can't a narcissistic parent
will often use fear-based tactics to
scare kids into doing what the parent
wants or to just make them feel they
won't be loved unless they do exactly
what they're told there's an intolerance
or Disobedience there's also gaslighting
which is a term you might have heard
that means
someone will say that didn't happen when
it actually did what I've decided I'd
like to do is to formally ask you
to come in
and be the next chief executive of this
company
I don't think I'm the right person well
you know I'm pretty smart and I think
you are
some examples of gaslighting here would
be in the conversation that Logan has
with shiv saying you're the one you're
the one who's going to take this to the
next level yet in the future every time
she tries to get him to say that
he almost pretends it never happened
it's been disgusting but I don't think
we're quite at the point where no not
anytime soon we've uh we've discussed
the transition and some arrangements we
will bore you no
there's going to be a point at which
he's just not going to be in control and
that is incredibly threatening to a
narcissist underneath the narcissism is
an incredibly fragile person kids pick
up on this in some way usually when
they're younger and they realize oh we
can't say that we can't do that we can't
behave this way because it will really
hurt this parent and something awful is
going to happen that's why it's really
important to start with Logan because
everything that happens and unfolds is
because of him and because of his
narcissism Kendall Roy
Kendall is one of Logan's sons and he's
really lacking self-confidence
he's someone that has responded to this
world without a present father by
escaping it and pursuing drugs
substances he doesn't know how to have a
relationship with other people and
that's true for all of these kids they
don't know how to interact with people
the way they should because they were
never shown how to do that both by the
father as well as by the mother when you
talk about Kendall he's already been
married and divorced or separated at
this point he's this strange figure to
his kids they're present when he's on a
trip to Italy but they're not really
interacting with him in very meaningful
ways
hello Darlings how are you
lovely so um you're all going to be
taken up to the house
I'll be there in a minute guys
sometimes when someone who hasn't been
given lots of care and love when they
are offered something they really do
Dive Right In they really try to pursue
it they want more of it it's over
stimulating because they've sought it so
you will see him overreact to something
or jump into a relationship when there's
no basis for a relationship there all
right so what are we going to do here
I feel like we should maybe buy an
island put in a giant island-sized bed
and just
spin to Dundee you want to come to
Dundee one of the most heartbreaking
scenes even though it doesn't look
heartbreaking at first is when Kendall
goes in and guts Walter
Kendall what the are you doing what
the is going on yeah sorry about
the cloak and dagger
I just needed some time to untangle all
your find the profit centers keep
the union up our back we're already
fully operational on seven why
because my dad told me to
with Kendall there is this push and pull
rebel against the father side with him
Rebellion against father's side with him
I think each kid has that but Kendall
makes an attempt to overthrow his father
say there's a vote of no confidence or
later to on the news live say his Reign
ends now he allowed all these illegal
operations to happen but the interesting
thing is it's always a push and pull and
it's either always the father getting
what he wants or Kendall feels like it's
always what he would want there's no in
between there's no sharing because there
was no sharing a narcissistic parent
takes up all the room and all the space
there is no place for anyone else
Siobhan Roy
defend that all you want but Jerry can
look after herself yeah I know that I'm
not defending Jerry yeah hide under the
covers with Mommy
oh off Siobhan oh you love showing
your pee pee to everyone but someday you
know you're actually gonna have to
something the relationship that shiv has
with her brothers and that they have
with hers is one of competition and
that's a result of the parenting too
it's pitting one kid against the other
we see that in her marriage to Tom
she doesn't want to talk about kids she
doesn't want to talk about his fears of
going to prison she just wants him there
when she wants him and doesn't want him
there and she doesn't want him there
talk to him in hungry what yeah
I don't think I want to do that Jim
uh oh hello is this the replicant
apartment yeah my meat puppet has
stopped working oh chef chef
when we talk about chiv I think it's
important to mention the relationship
she has with her mother I didn't think
I've ever won a single battle in my
whole life hmm
I was 10 mom he's a kid
you were 13.
and you knew how to twist the knife you
knew then and you know now
and I might cry
oh yeah where's the onion
I don't understand what a kid is
supposed to do with that even as an
adult do you go back and redo your
childhood I mean that that's ridiculous
Roman Roy
I'd lay you badly Bradley you gladly can
I remind you Roman that so far as I'm
concerned nothing has ever happened
between us other than of a professional
nature got to be curious though right a
young fighter in his prime technically
raw but you know hungry if you were to
ask shiv and Kendall and even Connor
they probably look at Roman and say oh
he's the youngest child he's a baby
stereotypically people often look at the
baby as the one that gets away with
anything Roman's relationship with Jerry
is pretty interesting he gets turned on
when she degrades him not to sound too
much like a psychiatrist but one reason
this might be is because of mother
issues now it's degrading it's it's
humiliation that she offers him but
there's a little bit of a power Dynamic
here in the sexual excitement it could
be that he has been so degraded by his
father over time to make it sexual and
to get something out of it he's taking
control of it okay I'm very sorry Jerry
no you don't get to speak
you have always been a disappointment
but this is just you have gone beyond
the pale
uh-huh oh yeah
I think his lack of self-confidence
though shows whenever he has a chance to
be in control of something he really
wants the opportunity but he also
completely fails Roman is also an
interesting one to talk about because of
his name sometimes Logan refers to him
as Romulus so Romulus and Remus the
Twins were both Supple by a wolf very
interesting to compare Logan to a wolf
but the other point here is that Romulus
succeeded he beat Remus Rome was named
Rome there's this hope that Roman will
do that I mean there's a lot in a name
Roman can't do any of that he can barely
even say yeah I I don't want my dad here
anymore and vote of no confidence he
can't say it he's shrinking down in his
chair literally and the father just
bulldozes over him Conor Roy hey oh
wonderful
what is it well oh yes yes it's a uh
it's a girl
perfect it's sourdough starter
Connor
is delusional that's his way of dealing
with a life where he does not have the
love from his father but Conor focuses
on things that really are not possible
hey
[Applause]
hey there's dinner rolls ripping out
there as we speak Potter I Am Alive
there are always issues when you serve
this many people but I think on the
whole it's going very well
complacent you're fired you're all fire
idiots
he focuses on these things that really
are inconsequential he doesn't have a
basis for reality he's not psychotic
he's not having a break from reality
he's not hearing things or seeing things
he's just delusional he thinks he's
going to be
president of the United States he's not
really held a job one thing that parents
who are narcissistic often end up
imparting on their kids is that
relationships are transactional Connors
got this in his life in his relationship
with Willa Willa is essentially a call
girl and that person becomes his
girlfriend but over time you know he
wants to marry her again he's detached
from the reality here that she probably
doesn't want to marry him at all and
then he gets offended this is his own
narcissism coming out he gets offended
that she doesn't necessarily have an
answer for him when he says that he
wants to marry her
come on how bad can it be right
yeah why not you know we'll have fun I
don't know many people that would want
to marry someone who says sure I'll
spend the rest of my life with you but
that's what she does so in some ways
he's okay with that because it's a
transaction he's asked her to marry him
he will provide she will be with him Tom
wamscans
so moving outside of the immediate
family you have Tom wamscans who ends up
becoming shiv's husband Tom seems to be
this almost
milk toast kind of guy who just follows
shiv around literally follows her
towards the bathroom when she's visiting
her father in the hospital and proposes
there's something I have to say to you
Siobhan Roy
oh my God
will you marry me what
I love you
and I wanted to do something to make all
this better
and I thought well your dad's still with
us wouldn't that be a nice thing
we can get a quick wedding
is it about my dad dying in a sterile
environment that screams big romantic
gesture to you but what's interesting
about Tom and this outside person is he
does Express his emotion he does Express
I really love you I want to have you as
my wife he does Express I don't want to
be in prison he does Express fear and
again it's met with nothing because the
Rory family doesn't know how to respond
to emotions Tom's been mistreated so
when he gets a chance to mistreat other
people he takes that whereas some people
might say you know that feels really
terrible when people do that to me I'm
not going to do that to anyone else
Tom's a Roy now anyone I talk to I
effectively kill
here
that's the death pet Greg
take a look
I mean I feel like I might not like it
in the Death Pit
go ahead
the invitation to the Death Pit is one
Greg does not want but he does it anyway
he is somewhat forced to do it but then
he realizes this is really bad how can I
distance myself from this enough so we
steal some pages he doesn't want to do
this to other people he doesn't want to
be a part of this Tom might be doing
some of the things he does also to
endear himself to shiv who functions in
that way that ruthless cunning way he
can't get close to her emotionally so
maybe this is the next thing and then
she'll like him
cousin Greg I'm actually I'm actually
here to see you
stand back
who are you what are you doing I'm Craig
I'm good I'm Marianne's Greg your nephew
when I was looking at Greg to really try
to understand his psychology
I found that I didn't have a ton to talk
about which I think is really a
reflection of his experience in the
family he's just there Greg's
introduction in the show is very
interesting he's in this costume he's
just smoked and he ends up vomiting all
through the costume Through The Eyes
through the mouth around all these
children who are at the theme park it's
somewhat indicative of his role in the
family he's his character and people
don't know really what to make of him
what do you make of vomiting walking
Muppet the other thing about Greg that's
important to mention is he's the most
human he's the most relatable for a lot
of people because you do see him face
these situations almost as we do the way
audience members do
and think what do I do with this how do
I respond to this and that's what we're
doing while we view the show that's what
Greg's doing in real time as he sees
this family so he sees the trappings of
this family and isn't sure that he
really wants to be a part of it and even
though he comes across as this Opie kind
of guy but cousin Greg is not as goofy
as you think he is something I sometimes
say to people I work with and see in
therapy particularly to parents if I'm
seeing their children will be if your
child
feels at all the way I do and I'm only
feeling this for a few minutes we really
need to work on how you communicate with
your kid so you can learn a lot from the
feelings you get when you're sitting
with people
when I sit and watch succession I really
enjoy the episode but I'm ready for time
to be up so I think people like to know
okay I can get close to this really
horrible dysfunctional thing but I can
pull back so there's a way to look at
what might be scary to us thinking our
family doesn't work that nobody loves us
and yet we can withdraw from it by
turning the TV off at any point
[Music]